-You were nice enough
to do our show
when we were in our other studio
with no audience.
And here we are,
back in the main studio...
-Yeah.
-...with an audience.
How does that feel?
-They like it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I mean, isn't that amazing?
Doesn't that sound great?
-Yeah.
-I mean, it feels right, right?
I mean, it must be a -- it's --
just a sea change for you.
-Oh, it was -- Really,
I mean, honestly, this is --
Right now, we have 58 people,
and they sound --
I told them earlier --
they sound like
Madison Square Garden.
-Yeah. Yeah. My God.
-It's great.
-And, then, also,
all the Zoom guests...
-Yeah.
-...which
you're still probably doing,
but it --
this changes everything.
-Yeah. And people like you,
for coming into the studio,
means a world of difference
to us,
so thank you so much again
for doing this.
I appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know we ask you a lot of --
a lot of favors.
You're like, "Yeah, dude,
I do have another job,"
but we always ask you to come.
How are you doing?
How's -- How's --
How's the city for you --
New York City?
I know you just...
-I mean, it just is --
I just love it so much.
I see something --
You know, my life right now
is pretty much the same
as it was
during the lockdown
during last
late spring and summer,
but just that I now get to be
traveling through the city
and walking through the city
and -- and going to work.
Besides that, I really --
you know, we order out for food.
This is the most social life
that I've had in --
you know, well,
since the last time I was here.
-Really?
You don't go out to restaurants?
-Don't -- No, not at all.
-Oh, really? Not even --
-We've tried a couple of times,
you know, sitting and --
But, you know, I --
We went to one, I remember,
that was on an -- an avenue,
not on a street,
and I was sitting there
in this sort of plastic and...
-Yeah.
-...you know, wood thing.
-Yeah, they build these huts,
like, in the middle
of the street, yeah.
-And I was sitting there
and getting drunk on sake.
And -- And I'd sort of
look over my shoulder,
and there'd be, you know,
a big container truck
coming, you know,
about a foot past my head.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
-I just was like not --
And then, also,
with the new advent of,
you know, in the last year --
or about a year and a half
of ebikes and escooters now...
-I'm out.
-Like, you walk out
of one of those sheds
where the restaurant is...
-[ Chuckling ] Sheds.
-...after all the sake...
[ Laughter ]
-Vvvvrrm!
-...and there's a scooter going
by with some kid going like 40.
[ Laughter ]
-They go -- It goes too fast.
How was it like
getting here tonight?
-Well, I mean, you just --
we were coming down Broadway,
and I was in the car
coming down.
And you -- you were asking,
like, about in -- in New York --
being back in New York.
-Yeah.
-And...you know, you just see
something every day.
I was coming, and I took a left
off of Broadway onto 50th
to come over here.
-Uh-huh.
-And there was a -- between --
50th between --
I guess it would have been
7th and 8th, Broadway and 8th,
there was a club that said
"Gentlemen's Club"
up at the top.
It had a big vertical, you know,
marquee.
-Yeah.
-And it said up at the top
"Gentlemen's Club,"
and then down below, it said,
"Live Models."
And then, the name of the club
was in huge block letters
running down,
called "Mixed Emotions."
[ Laughter ]
I'm --
-That's an --
-What would that --
Yeah, what would that be
for the strip club?
[ Laughter ]
Mixed Emotions.
-You can name your club
anything.
-Yeah, Mixed Emotions.
-Mixed Emotions.
-Yes, it's like a feeling of fun
mixed with shame and regret.
[ Laughter ]
-What an odd --
What an odd name.
What an odd name choice.
[ Laughter ]
-For your bachelor party.
-Oh, yeah.
We were gonna go to Scores,
but we ended up taking --
taking him to Mixed Emotions.
[ Laughter ]
This city is the greatest.
But -- But you shoot the show
here in New York.
Is it -- What is it like filming
something in New York...
-It is so crazy.
-...as opposed to anywhere else
in the -- in the world?
You've -- You've shot
so many films and TV shows.
-You know, years ago, I shot
a film with Robert Mitchum
at the Utah State Penitentiary,
which is
a maximum-security prison,
but it also --
it's a huge complex --
but it also has
a minimum-security section.
And, you know, we go in and --
and have to go through the --
you know,
a battery of sort of security
and so on and so forth --
this is
many, many, many years ago.
And then we also had
different convicts
that were extras in the scenes.
And then
we'd all have lunch together,
and, actually, our caterers
would cater the lunch and...
-You'd eat with the convicts?
-Yeah, we'd eat
with the different convicts
that were --
that were extras in the scene.
[ Light laughter ]
And, you know, a film or
television production company,
when they film on location,
it's like an invasion.
I mean, they really...
You get a permit to shoot
where you're gonna --
you know, the block or the house
or the --
wherever it is -- the road,
and you own that spot.
I mean, you're showing up
with trucks and campers...
-Lighting.
-...and hundreds of people
and, you know,
cables everywhere.
I mean, you own that spot.
-Yeah.
And shooting
at the Utah State Penitentiary
was the only place that
I'd ever been filming
where there was never a second
where you thought
that you owned that spot
or that you were in charge
in any way.
-No. You're in a prison.
-Yeah. You're in a -- Yeah.
And -- And you're --
And it wasn't even really
the administrators
that felt like
they were in charge.
I mean, obviously, they're --
you know,
it felt like the convicts
are in charge of that territory.
You know, they're --
they're seated a certain --
you know, that space,
and that's -- they're in charge.
-Oh, yeah.
-And it really felt like that.
It really felt like
we were guests.
Every moment we were there,
-And do you talk --
-That's what it's like
shooting on location
in New York.
[ Laughter ]
Exactly, actually.
I mean, the city
is very accommodating, you know?
They give us, you know,
tax breaks and everything else.
-Yeah, well,
you're great for the city.
-Yes, but New Yorkers --
it's a fantastic --
it's so healthy --
New Yorkers don't ever let you
think for a moment
that you're in charge -- ever.
[ Laughter ]
You know, like...
-Yeah, they don't --
Yeah. You're --
"Yeah, yeah, get out of the way.
This is my bus --
This is my bus stop."
-Yeah, this is -- Yeah.
-"Yeah, but we're filming
a scene here."
They're like, "I don't care."
-"Yeah, well,
I'm going right over there,
okay?"
-"I'm going over" -- Yeah.
-"I'm going over there, right?"
-"I'm drinking my coffee."
-So you stop filming,
and you let the person
go over there, you know?
-I love this city so much.
-Yeah.
-Do not change. Do --
Never -- Never change,
New York, please.
-It's the greatest,
greatest city.
I mean, just the mix
of idiosyncrasies
just come together.
I find -- Driving down here,
I was looking at all the people
in the street,
and -- and it's New Yorkers
that make New York so wonderful.
And -- And you realize that,
as a group, I adore them.
You know, they're -- they're
insufferable individually,
but, as a group,
they're fantastic, you know?
'Cause you mix
all those idiosyncrasies
and eccentricities together,
and it makes this amazing stew,
you know?
-Yeah.